this is your first podcast is that right
it's my first podcast and it's already
feeling like I've done it wrong no what
are you talking about oh this is oh but
you know what I can tell this is you
yeah this is you which is my guess is
you don't like to watch yourself do your
work no it's very rare that I like that
I like it on this on on Fleischman is in
trouble I like that I like watching it
which by the way I I told you this
before we started Fleischmann is in
trouble with it's with you and Claire
Danes and Jesse Eisenberg and I was
binge watching it
yesterday and it got up to three
episodes and then it said you you know
we're so spoiled now yeah and I am
loving it really loving it and in this
this story I did not read the book so
I'm I'm coming in
with with no awareness and it's such a
good story and it's so compelling that
it got to the end of the third episode
and they said yeah now you have to wait
for more and I became enraged and pulled
my flat screen off the wall wow and so
strong yeah oh I didn't mean that for
that to come out but with a slight tug
of my massive arms
and a bit of a torque of my perfect
six-pack and I'm just describing what
happened uh it easily came out of the
wall
I threw it uh up into the sky it must
have been poorly installed yeah I like
torque of my six-pack I've never heard
that that's a swipe was it a slight
torque and just then uh some
photographers were there and they took
beautiful black and white photographs
were you oiled at the time I was oiled
and bare chested and then I threw the
flat screen up into the sky and it went
into the sun something yeah and just
disappeared but anyway uh I love it and
I'm also a fan of your co-stars uh yes
Claire Danes is a lovely person
obviously very talented Jesse Eisenberg
um uh she first came on my show many
years ago when he was just starting out
I think for squid and the whale and a
couple of days later a handwritten note
yeah showed up on my desk and I had been
doing my talk show at that point for
like 15 years and this handwritten note
shows up that's adorable and from this
very nice boy wrote me a beautiful
letter
thanking me for having him on the show
and he had me he's like that guy had me
and then a couple of other times I've
received a nice Jesse Eisenberg so uh
Jesse if you're out there I need another
letter soon he is a sweet boy he's a
really sweet now he's a sweet man 40 40
years old well according to Wikipedia
he's 67. oh damn he is the he is the
best guy I love him take it easy no he
is the best
the funniest just like like a guy in the
public eye have you seen him rip a TV
off a wall
yeah I'd like to see Jesse do that yeah
I guess what the walls were made of
oatmeal
what a weird insult hey Jessie Jessie if
you're listening if you had to rip a
flat screen off a wall the wall would
have to be made of oatmeal
it's gonna write you a letter about that
we'll be right back with more insults no
one's ever said in the history of
mankind I have I'm curious because I
have not talked to you about this but
to me you are a very natural talent and
it makes me feel like you must have
known you wanted to do this at an early
age but that was not the case you had
other dreams other schemes I mean I now
looking back yes I was very young when I
decided this but at the time it didn't
because again grew up in La did not have
these dreams of
actress work I'm not even gonna say
stardom so like being a working I didn't
think about it
um and then yeah I went to a performing
arts high school and I played the piano
and I used to be pretty good at the
piano but I was never gonna be like a
Pianist
right let's just watch the language okay
sorry uh and then I needed so I quit the
piano and then I needed an elective to
stay in the academy and so I just said
I'll do acting because I don't know how
to sing or dance or play the saxophone
so I did that and then now I do this for
a living did you feel like Freaks and
Geeks was the first moment where you
felt like oh this
this is gelling or with their
experiences before Freaks and Geeks that
was my first experience that was the
first thing you hadn't done like a
commercial okay my first thing was one
line on Freaks and Geeks opposite Ben
Foster who was amazing in the show like
everybody in that show was amazing yeah
and I had to go through like
periodically I have to go through this
big box of old photos usually like for
set decoration for whatever I'm working
on they always want to you know like put
your own family photos and photos of you
when you're a little kid up so I go
through this box and I found this photo
that I hadn't seen forever and it was
the day
that I had done this job this Freaks and
Geeks one day of work first day ever and
I remember this moment I remember
sitting there like talking to my dad and
his girlfriend and being like it was so
crazy there was somebody so I'd never
even been on a set and it's like you
stand on this thing it's like a piece of
paper or a tape and they call it a Mark
and I was eating a banana and then it
was time for us to shoot the thing and
somebody came and just held my banana
from me and then like gave it back to me
and then somebody else did that with my
jacket and it was like it blew every
part of it completely blew my mind and
now I'm just jaded his head yeah why am
I holding my own [ __ ] banana
where's our banana holder
[Applause]
Lizzy's locked herself in her trailer
she won't come out
[ __ ] Ringling circles you're running
here it's it's sweet that you say that
because I I am still very in touch with
when I first got started and again this
is you know you were a baby when this
happened but my uh my writing partner
Greg Daniels and I came out to LA and we
had our first job right out of college
working on a show on HBO called not
necessarily the news and they showed us
where our desks were going to be like
here's where you work you'll have desks
at we had desks that faced each other
like bankers and you're gonna sit in
this room and pump out you know just
write gags on these typewriters
um I'm sorry what year was this
1985. this is 19. this is September
1985. and yeah it's typewriters that's
crazy and so the first thing they showed
us our office and they said oh by the
way this here is the snack room
so and it was a room that was just you
know had like
you know popcorn potato chips sodas uh
cookies you know junk food snacks snacks
yeah could you actually list a few more
snacks
[Laughter]
a Cracker Jack say okay which would be a
popcorn with caramel get it a Snickers
bar anyway the Greg Daniels who went on
to you know uh do the American office
and
um you know a million other shows uh and
Parks and Rec and
um I'm gonna list all of his shows now
and more snacks yeah
no Greg
King he went he went there and he came
back and he had a paper plate and it had
some potato chips and cookies and stuff
on and he was like this we get to have
this now keep in mind he's 22 I'm 22.
and he's like we get to have this I
don't think we have to pay and he'd like
eat them and then he'd go um I'll be
right back and it was the pure joy
totally which you know uh and now here
we are a million years later but I still
remember the joy of I'm sorry you know
it when I was at Saturday Night Live at
this at the craft service table so we
can have this and do we have to sign for
it right no that's a craft service table
anybody that comes to visit that's the
thing that blows their mind the most it
takes you back to those moments but I
feel that way about like an office
supply closet we like pens yes and like
like Post-its you just take as many as
you want yeah yeah that's crazy and you
sometimes think and to this day if I
grab a cup I mean this is my you know a
podcast company building yeah but if I
if I grabbed a couple of my favorite
pens we all know what they are
um the pilot precisely what are they oh
god and anyway but you know what I mean
there's a part of me that thinks I might
get stopped on the way out the door yeah
and you make us pay for snacks this is I
went and I bought one of those 1940s
um those machines that dispense
sandwiches after that yeah and so I
installed an automatic of course you
know what it's called and what the [ __ ]
and if people want toilet paper they
have to put in and you have to find you
have to find nickels and dimes from the
1950s
such a fun office oh it's terrific